The two remaining
bachelorettes
prepare for their
final date with Ben.
I just really wish we
didn't have to go on
this last date
as a threesome.
There's enough
of him to go around.
I just don't like to
share Ben with anyone.
When I just
said that,
I mean, I'm talking
about... his dick.
Oh.
I was like, so it's...
uh-ya-ya-ya-ya, ding.
(groaning) ding!
Like, corn, like eating
corn and a typewriter.
You guys slept
together already?
No, no.
I mean, yeah,
like what do
you consider
sleeping together?
It's like, you
know, who cares?
I mean, isn't that
what this show is,
like, what--
♪♪
I just want to start off our
last night with a toast
to the two
most beautiful...
You know what,
I'm like not in a
champagne mood,
I'm sorry.
Like, can I just get
a cranberry vodka?
I'm like more than flirting
with a yeast right now.
Like when I pee it's
like somebody's
blowing glass
down there.
Thank you, cool.
Coolio, you're
the best.
Okay, go,
yeah-yeah-yeah,
this is about you,
not us--
To the two most
beautiful
classy women.
I'm so thankful
I've had the chance to go on
this journey with you both.
So cheers.
Cheers.
Cheers, queers.
(shattering)
Sorry, sorry-sorry-
sorry-sorry,
like, not totally
my fault.
I'm sorry...
they're like...
Whoa... so...
But seriously, can I just
get one more of those,
like, but like, vodka.
We're all adults so.
Tonight, I have an incredibly
hard decision to make
about who I want to escort
into the Love Tub, so...
Like, when
is it lice?
Like leg-wise.
Oh, Amy, you have...
an amazing spirit.
I'd never even
heard of the game
leaky submarine
until I met you.
Hmm...
What's leaky
submarine?
He plugs all
my holes.
I thought I'd
ask you both
about your dreams
for the future.
My dream for
the future is
right now if somebody brings
us curly fries, right?
It's like,
that'd be good,
just soak up
all the booze.
We're just like drinking
and it's like,
ugh, perfect storm.
Tiffany, if I ask you to
join me in the Love Tub
would you be willing
to move to Utah
to start our
lives together?
Yes, I grew up
around horses.
When I ride I feel
like I'm flying.
Amy...
Moving on.
Tiffany, what do you
think is the secret
to a lasting
relationship?
My parents have been
married for over 40 years
and they taught me that
the key ingredients
are trust
and respect.
That's so
beautiful.
What do you
think Amy?
Okay well I think I'm--
maybe I may have told you
this at one point, but...
I dated this guy
Ricky for like...
five months, okay?
Real piece of shit.
He was like my dealer
and then he wasn't
and then he was.
La, la, la.
He made out with
my sister...
She's a slut.
She would be like
amazing on this show.
If they're doing
the next one.
♪♪
(Exhaling)
Tiffany, Amy, I've never had
to make a harder choice.
You are both--
I'm sorry.
Do we actually
order curly fries
or where do we
stand with that
whole situation
right now?
Whoo.
Okay, they have
the fries.
They're just not bringing 'em
because we're filming.
Like, no one
cares, it's fine.
Like, it's fine,
it's fine?
It's fine.
I've made
my decision.
♪♪
Tiffany...
would you please join
me in the Love Tub?
Yes.
Yeah.
(laughing)
Congratulations.
♪♪
Are we going to
see Ben right now?
(man)
No, Ben's in the Love
Tub with Tiffany.
He chose her.
Yeah right,
he chose her.
He would never choose
her, she's a--
She's a bitch.
She's dumb.
She looks like--
one time, this lady,
I was like, eww, oh,
Tiffany, you're so... ew.
Can somebody
hold my hair?
Okay, guys, I'm--
I know I said some
bad things about you
but please
hold my hair.
(retching)
( Amy )
I'm okay.